an investigation is underway into the
deaths of at least four nursing home
residents they were taken to a warehouse
that was turned into a shelter to ride
out ida now it was meant to keep them
safe
maria virial is following this story in
new orleans maria this did not go the
way officials had hoped good morning to
you
good morning gail that's exactly right
state
state health officials are actually
saying this location was unsafe and it
was unhealthy there were reports of
people sleeping on mattresses on the
floor they weren't being fed or changed
regularly and there was no social
distancing in fact when inspectors
showed up at the location they were
turned away from the site and now family
members and even the governor are
demanding answers
the last of 843 nursing home residents
were relocated from this warehouse
thursday after state health officials
deemed conditions inside unsafe families
rushed to the site looking for answers
blindsided by the news of course they
should be held accountable
everyone that was here that didn't help
the people that needed help
when they could have made any kind of
phone call governor john bel edwards
vowed legal action against anyone found
responsible we're going to do a full
investigation into whether the owner of
the facilities failed to keep residents
safe
and whether he intentionally obstructed
efforts to check in on them with
hurricane recovery efforts entering
their fifth day and hundreds of
thousands still without power and other
critical supplies edwards urged calm
i know that people are anxious and tired
i'm asking people to be patient
but patience is wearing thin
this is killian louisiana a picturesque
town nestled on the banks of the tig
fall river
to get there we drove by row after row
of ripped out trees and though it's just
about 60 miles from new orleans the
folks who live here say they feel like
they're on an island
killian police chief erin comier says
almost no help has come from the state
they dropped off one pallet of water and
50 tarps
how long did that last that lasted all
of probably two hours
people here are desperate to start
rebuilding like town alderman kenny
beije we were with him on his first
visit home since ida hit
we could only get to his neighborhood on
a four-wheeler with most of the streets
still full of water
what bae hai found left him speechless
what are you seeing
while beijing plans to rely on the
kindness of his neighbors for now
chief comier says that's not enough if
we don't get mres
water
diapers commodities just anything to
help these citizens that
it's going to be a very tough time help
we just need help
back here in new orleans there are
several parts of the city that have
started to receive power like here in
the french quarter rebuilding and you
know picking up the pieces will start to
begin but just to clarify those nursing
home patients actually were here in
facilities in new orleans and they were
taken to baton rouge they were evacuated
there we did reach out to the owner of
the facilities bob dean he did not
immediately respond to cbs news but he
did make a comment to our local baton
rouge affiliate saying we only had five
deaths within six days and normally with
850 people you'll have a couple a day so
we did really good with taking care of
those people
vlad
all right maria thank you very much